okay I know this is like isn't my beat
or whatever I'm supposed to do like
International stuff but I have been
watching this account all week and I
cannot get enough this lady is making
mozzarella cheese right now but this is
only the beginning she's making
mozzarella cheese in her like Old World
Garb and she's about to do something
insane like look at this here she goes
she puts air into it wait for this next
part
I'll be making mozzarella sticks that's
those are corn flakes she's now making
the batter she's gonna make this amazing
like crust she's making mozzarella
sticks with her own cheese this lady
lives in Virginia that is close to me
how do I get in on these mozzarellas
just look at this
God
I've watched this video a hundred times
so good who why do people like this
exist how do they do this what is going
on